emmanuel je le connais depuis plusieurs
années il a fait partie d'une équipe de
jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne avec ma
fille alors je les ai vus évoluer dans
ce groupe et puis qu'a menée par
bernadette guillotin et c'est comme cela
que avec marie thérèse on a pensé à lui
et un jour je vais manuel que tu es ici
pour la joc et qui me dit on vient vous
chercher quelqu'un bien moi j'aimerais
donner quelques années de ma vie pour
l'église j'ai 28 ans j'habite guerre
sous poissy et donc depuis septembre
donc j'ai démarré un une mission une
mission d'église en tant qu animateur
pastoral ans était populaire rôle c'est
de en lien avec la communauté
paroissiale de poissy de mettre des
moyens pour que les jeunes des quartiers
de poissy puisse être écoutée et
entendue donc et aussi j'ai une mission
d' annonce de la foi auprès de ces
jeunes pour que le christ puisse être au
milieu de leur vie ce qui est sur toutes
les questions que vous vous posez sur le
monde sont les baies sur dieu vous vous
lâchez quoi et les passions et vous
mettez toutes les passions de la vie
c'est dans une relation on va peut-être
pouvoir répondre on va peut-être laissé
en suspens aussi parce que va-t-on
arrêter toutes les réponses
quinze minutes de temps et on verra que
dans le temps ça sera aussi notre fil
conducteur aux missions et se découpe en
trois axes donc j'ai une mission de
présence physique sur le quartier donc
comme moi elle se bat comment elle se
présente c'est par une création de
permanences jeunes au sein de du
quartier donc dans le local du
presbytère donc j'accueille les jeunes
qui veulent me rencontrer pour que je
puisse les écouter don puisse échanger
sur leurs difficultés sur leurs attentes
sur leur vie aussi leur victime parce
qu'ils vivent des vies pas facile les
rencontres emmanuel depuis le début de
l'année donc j'ai entendu parler que un
groupe de lycéens et skréla les secrets
donc il a il a demandé à plusieurs gens
de venir du bon se retrouver puis a fait
une petite équipe
alors il faudrait parler moi chaque
question je fais du foot américain
d'accord natation musique violon courir
les gens à vide les tripes ou valérie
les délires bref d'accord toi qu'est ce
que tu en penses ouais bah on divise
toujours on alterne les orties enfin
joyeuse et des sorties qui ont pu ce
rapport avec dieu et en ce moment on
parle surtout de mari parce que comme on
va on va faire un voyage à lourdes en
trois mois donc on apprend à mieux la
connaître
parle de ça j'étais tout comme ça
ensuite après j'ai une mission d'
annonce de la foi donc pour ce faire
donc jacques j'accompagne des jeunes
dans des études bibliques donc je fais
de l'individuel et du groupe et
j'accompagne aussi des jeunes au
sacrement de la confirmation donc cette
année donc j'ai six jeunes qui se
prépare six jeunes du quartier qui se
prépare à la confirmation donc pour moi
c'est une grâce et une joie de pouvoir
les accompagner à ce sacrement emmanuel
il nous motive il est très dynamique
donc avec nous on s'amuse et ça nous
paraît pas chiant leucate et donc il
essaie de faire et je sais que de faire
en sorte que ce soit le mieux pour nous
que c'est un aspect tout en s'amusant on
étudie la fois tout en s'amusant oui
dynamique il fait pas trop enfin comme
c'était un prof en fait il ya beaucoup
d'échangés entre une tout ce passe bien
mais si on a besoin si on a un souci si
on veut parler d'orientation avec lui
est toujours là il à votre écoute depuis
qu'il est là les jeunes sont beaucoup
plus présents et vraiment comme il dit
il est un rassembleur il nous l'a
confirmé j'aime prier en chantant donc
pour moi le champ d'à on dit c'est prier
deux fois où vous priez trois fois
j'étais content mais chanter ses prix
trois fois et donc bah j'ai monté un
groupe de gospel sur dans ma ville
qu'est carrières sous poissy rouge se
regroupent à peu près entre vingt et
trente choristes aussi bien des jeunes
que des moins jeunes aussi bien des
chrétiens catholiques des protestants
que des évangélistes mais aussi des
jeunes là qu'ils sont
et donc à travers le chant à travers les
louanges à travers la traverse à
travailler va
j'essaye un peu de les ramener aussi à
la foi chrétienne à la fois vers la foi
en jésus christ
m
et
il y aller
il y a